[تصفيق]
في 72 مليون شخص حول العالم بيستخدموا
اكثر من 300 لغه لغات ما بينسمع لها صوت
في بيت عربي قديم بالشام القديمه جذبني
هذا المكان من 13 سنه تماما بكل تفاصيله
صامته حتى رواده هن جزء من 72 مليون شخص
حول العالم
رواد هذا المكان قد ما اجتمعوا بالحفلات
بالمناسبات بالاعياد ما بينسمع لهم صوت لا
موسيقى لا اوبرا لا اغاني بتجذب انتباهن
الا تصاور بصريه ولغه الجسد كان ينفتني
الجرس جرس يتكيف مع سكانه فصار بلا صوت
اللي هو عباره عن اضاءه فقط هذا الجرس
بشوفه بكل بيت شخص اصم بالاضافه لعده
اضويه بتكون موجوده بكل بيت شخصا لحتى
تكون بديل عن الصوت
بلشت ابني معاهم خبره عمرها 13 سنه حركه
بحركه ما اب ايماءه واشاره باشاره
علموني انه لغه الجسد ايماءات الوجه حركات
الشفاه واشارات الايدين هن الوسيله
التواصل كل شخص خانه عصبه السمعي علموني
انه حركات الوجه هي اساسيه بالتواصل
فمثلا
هيك اشاره غضب
اشاره تذمر
اشاره سعيد
بلشت تحلل وقارن ما بين مجتمع الصم ومجتمع
السامعي
فمجتمع الصم بما انه هو بيمتلك لغه وهي
اللغه مثل كل اللغات الى خواص خاصه الى
تعابير مجازيه خاصه
ففي الهن مفردات كانت تلفتني مثلا انت اذا
كنت عم تحكي مع رفيقك وقلت له خلاص ما عاد
بدي اسمعك بلغه الاشاره بنقول انا قفلت
عيوني
واذا مثلا كنت عم تحكي بحديث وفجاه انت
قلت بدي اكمل هذا الحديث بالاشاره كتعبير
مجازي منقول انا ضبيت اشارتي
اذا بدك تقول انا بدي احكي قصه فبتقول انا
بدي اقشر قصه مو بدي احكي وانت احكي لي
انت قشرلي
طبعا بتختلف لغه الاشاره من بلد لبلد وهن
300 لغه مختلفه حول العالم موثق هذا هاي
اللغات
فمثلا كلمه شكرا بلغه الاشاره العربيه
شكرا شكرا
بلغه الاشاره الامريكيه شكرا وبلغه
الاشاره التركيه شكرا
والعرب بيستخدموا مفردات القاموس الاشاري
العربي ومع هيك بيكون في اختلاف ما بين كل
بلد والثاني متل اختلاف اللهجات المحكيه
فمثلا الكلام السوري هو بيختلف عن المصري
بيختلف عن التونسي والاشارات نفس الموضوع
حتى الاشارات التونسيه هي اقرب للاشارات
الفرنسيه
والاشارات اللبنانيه هي اقرب للاشارات
الامريكيه اما الاشارات السوريه الكبار
بالعمر محافظين على لغه الاشاره العربيه
السوريه ما كتير بيحبوها تتدخل الاشارات
اجنبيه
طبعا العرب في لهم كمان اختلاف باللهجات
هلا الكل حسب القاموس الاشاري العربي
معروف انه سوريا هي العلم اللي عليه
نجمتين
بالكويت بيقولوا عن سوريا سوريا
لجمال السوريين اللي شافوا الكويت بسوريا
بالخليج بيقولوا عن سوريا سوريا نسبه
لبياع العرقسوس اللي هو رسخ في بالهم
كصوره بصريه وفي منهم بقولوا عن سوريا
نسبه لسوء الحميديه
طبعا الاختلافات بتمتد على مستوى
المحافظات نحن كاشاره سوريه عربيه كمان
بتختلف اشاراتنا من محافظه لتانيه
فبامكاننا نعرف هذا الشخص اذا هو من الشام
ولا من حمص ولا من حلب
بالشام نحن بنقول عن اشاره صبر بهذا الشكل
بحمص بيستخدموها بهذا الشكل بحلب
بيستخدموها بهذا الشكل طبعا الاتحاد
العالمي للصن هو لقى حل لهذا الاختلاف
وحدد اشارات باشارات عالميه وهيك صاروا
الصم يتواصلوا مع بعض كمجتمع اي حدا باي
مكان مع اي حدا ثاني باي مكان ثاني
بيتواصلوا مع بعض بمكالمات الفيديو
وبالرسائل الفيديو وبتقنيات البث المباشر
لدرجه انه انا اي ابديت بعمله عندي على
الانستغرام بلاقي فيه شخص من المشاهير
الصم عم يحكي عن خبر عن قضيه عن اي قصه او
موضوع علمي
هذا الشيء سهل التواصل بيناتهم لدرجه انه
خلاهن مجتمع مفتوح على بعضه منغلق على
السامعين
انا عرفت بفيروس كورونا بسبب الصم قبل ما
اعرفه بسبب الاشخاص السامعين في السرعه
انتشار المعلومه بدون مجتمع الصمت تنتشر
بيناتهم بشكل جدا سريع
هذا الشيء ايجابي كونه في معلومات صحيحه
عم تنتشر وعم يعلموا بعضهم كمجتمع متكامل
بس في نفس الوقت ممكن يكون مانو ايجابي
دائما في معلومات خاطئه هي مرسخه من هذا
المجتمع فمثلا اذا كانت الام صماء هي
وعندها بيبي صغير فهذا الطفل هو بينحرم من
الرضاعه الطبيعيه لانه مرسخ ببالهم اذا
الام صماء فعن طريق الحليب بينتقل الصمم
للطفل وهذا الشيء خاطئ علميا فلهيك كثير
مهم يكون موجود جسور التواصل اللي هنن
اشخاص اختصاصيين متقنين للغه الاشاره
موجودين بهذا العالم لينشفوا اخباره تنتقل
هاي الاخبار الصحيحه ضمن هذا العالم
جسور التواصل بسوريا بحسب وزاره العدل
كخبراء لغه اشاره العدد جدا قليل بسوريا
سبعه فقط وعدد المترجمين كمان اليف
لهيك بنحاول بكل مكان نكون فيه ننشر لغه
الاشاره خبير لغه الاشاره هو بيفيد الاصم
بانه يكون معه بالمحاكم بالافراح الامنيه
فلهيك في كتير صم ممكن ينحرموا من حقهم او
تتاجل افادتهم لانه خبير لغه الاشاره معنا
موجود او ما عنده وقت يجي فممكن يتاجل
باي مكان نكون موجودين فيه انا والصن
بنحاول ننشر هاي اللغه ومنحكي عنها مين
بيعرف ممكن اللي يشوفنا يحب يتعلمه من باب
المحبه فقط
في اشخاص بيحبوا يتعلموا من باب انه هنن
حابين يتعلموا لغه وممكن اشخاص يحبوا
يتعلمون يصير عندهم الحماس يصير عندهم شغف
ليصيروا جسر تواصل معنا
لنحقق الدمج ونحقق الدعم
والمساواه وهي اشاره الامل وهاي الصفقه
بالاشاره شكرا
[تصفيق]